do you have examples of cases where it
worked out well like uh that competition
is good for the progress of science yeah
it almost always is good in that sense
so
it's just painful for the individuals
and be yeah it doesn't have to be you
know nasty
although sometimes it is so on the space
like for the example with optics could
you comment on that one well yeah sure
let me there are several but i could
give you um
all right so i'll give you this example
that probably is
the most pertinent um
the first
polytechnic school like mit or caltech
was actually founded in france during
the french revolution it exists today
it's the egg called pulley technique
right
and two people who are there
uh were two young men in the 90s 1790s
uh named on the one hand francois arago
and the other jean baptiste bio they
both lived a long time well into the
1850s
arago became a major administrator of
science and b.o
his career started to peter out after
about the late teens
now
they are
sent on an expedition
which was one of the expeditions
involving measuring things to start the
metric system
there's a lot more to that story anyway
they come back arago gets separated
he's captured
by
pirates actually
wounds up in
uh tangier escapes is captured again
everybody thinks he's dead he gets back
to paris and so on he's greeted as a
hero and what not in the meantime b.o
has pretty much published some of the
stuff that he's done and arago doesn't
get much credit for it and aragog starts
to get very angry and bo is
known for this kind of thing so hour ago
anyway
b.o
starts investigating a new phenomenon in
optics involving something called
polarization
and he writes all kinds of stuff on it
arago
looks into this and decides to write
some things as well and actually
bo gets mostly interested in it when he
finds out that arago is doing stuff yeah
now bo is actually the better scientist
in a lot of ways but arago is furious
about this
so furious that he actually demands and
forces the leader of french science la
plus the marquis de la place
uh
and
cohorts to write a note in the published
journal saying oh excuse us
um
actually arago et cetera et cetera
blah blah so
arago continues to just hold this
antipathy and
fear of beo so what happens
1815
napoleon is finished at waterloo
right
a young frenchman by the name of august
stamfornel
was in the army
is going back to his home on the north
coast of france in normandy passes
through paris
arago is friends with
fresnel's uncle uh
who's the head of the egg called de
bozar at the time
anyway
fresnel is already interested in certain
things in light and he talks to arago
arago tells him a few things fresnel
goes home and fresnel is a brilliant
experimenter
he observes things and he's a very good
mathematician calculates things he
writes something up he sends it to hour
ago arago looks at it and arago says to
himself
i can use this to get back at b.o
he brings fresnel to paris sets him up
in
a room at the observatory where arago is
for fresnel to continue his work
paper after paper comes out
undercutting
everything b.o had done
what is it about jealousy and
just envy that could be an engine of
creativity
and and productivity
versus like an einstein where it seems
like not
i don't know which one is better i guess
it depends on the personality both are
useful engines and science
well in this particular story it's um
maybe even more interesting because
fresnel himself the young guy
he knew what arigo was doing with him
and he didn't like it yeah he didn't
want to get with he wrote his brother
said i you know i don't want to get an
argument with b i just want to do my
stuff
arago is using him
but it's because arago kept pushing him
to go into certain areas that stuff kept
coming out yeah
ego is beautiful
you